after two failed attempts South Sudan's
political rivals finally reach an
agreement President Salva Kiir and his
former deputy Riek Machar say they will
form a unity coalition government on
Saturday ending years of conflict no say
the race after the president resolved
the issues of states we have agreed to
form a government on the 22nd of
February without any further delay so
congratulations to all of us civil war
broke out in 2013 less than two years
after the country gained independence
from Sudan after decades of fighting
Keir accused mushara of attempting a
coup that led to a political dispute
deteriorating into a years long conflict
killing tens of thousands of people and
displacing millions more a deal to end
the fighting was signed in Ethiopia in
2018 there are a few things that are
still outstanding but we will resolve
them together through the transitional
government in the meantime things like
security and protection of all
opposition members in Juba are under my
full control the World Food Program has
been handing out aid packages in some
towns food has been scarce since the
conflict began a UN report has accused
all parties of deliberately starving
millions of people for political gain it
says government forces and other armed
groups have denied displaced people
access to aid by diverting millions of
dollars elsewhere and that constitutes a
war crime this crime of starvation which
involves destroying essential elements
for the survival of the civilian
population has been used by both sides
in the conflict as a way of getting
people to be to displace as well as a
way of intimidating the civilian
population the UN has called the
situation in South Sudan a humanitarian
crisis but there's hope the new unity
government will bring about positive
change Nicola gage al-jazeera